it was more than seven years ago when
Jorge's father Maria's husband Moises
Sanchez was kidnapped from their home in
Medellin Southeast Mexico
they started to say where's the man with
the taxi and when they took my husband
down he saw us and told them just don't
do anything to my family
well he made money as a taxi driver
Moises main job was running a free
newspaper called Low Neon it monitored
local authorities in Medellin his Moises
grilling the mayor foreign
body was found on the side of the road
dismembered the mayor was implicated he
fled he still hasn't been captured
Mexico's got one of the highest rates of
journalist murders in the world press
rights Advocates say what contributes to
that is a lack of Justice when a
reporter is killed it only adds to the
silence in this country
we full of Moises case to see how that
plays out
his son Jorge hasn't given up helping to
bring the case to a special prosecutor's
office set up specifically to
investigate crimes against journalists
Ricardo Sanchez is its lead the mayor is
still um at large there's only one
policeman in prison at the moment for
this and several members of the Ring who
organized it alleged to have organized
it also remain not in jail and not
sentenced what's your response to that
investigations regularly got to Veracruz
we haven't had a back breakthrough we
can give the police all the information
that we have but the prosecutor cannot
go and arrest somebody that's a word for
the police do you know where the mayor
is
there is a lot of Gossip around around
where he is we have sent that
information to the police officers and
nothing's happened they haven't done
anything well the reports that we have
is that there is he is not where the
rumor says that they are that he is
that's what they've told you do you
believe that
I cannot give you that information I
cannot give you a an answer to that
because
The Familiar frustration percentage is
his office's case resolution has got
better since he's been in charge but it
still stands at only six prosecutions
from more than 100 homicides across more
than a decade
meanwhile according to the federal
government over 40 percent of threats
and attacks on journalists come from
officials themselves usually local ones
and the attacks have only gone up under
the administration of President Andres
Manuel Lopez obrador by 85 percent
according to freedom of speech
organization article 19.
I asked the president what he was doing
to stop the impunity when journalists
were killed
I answered categorically that there is
no impunity and if you think otherwise
but the investigation is not close
Maldonado
just some of those killed many awaiting
Justice in Mexico this year John Holman
Al Jazeera Mexico